welcome to the heavy spoilers show i'm
your host paul and this video are
breaking down the ending of every
episode of love death and robot season
two
the eight episodes all come with their
own unique premise and plots
and in this video we're going to be
recapping and discussing the true
meaning behind each and every one of
them
full spoilers ahead so if you haven't
had a chance to check it out yet then i
highly recommend that you check out now
smash the thumbs up button if you enjoy
the breakdown and make sure you
subscribe for more videos like this
every day
without the way thank you for clicking
this now let's get into our breakdown of
love death and robot season two
okay so episode one is called automated
customer service
and it plays heavily on films like
terminator the matrix and
2001 a space odyssey humanity has now
reached a point where machines are
carrying out all manner of tasks
and the population's lives are based
completely around them
the episode chronicles the rise of the
machines as a woman is attacked by one
whilst trying to reach out to the
automated customer service line
that might just be in on it too now i've
got a puppy
a bit of a side tangent but it ties in
with the point and only recently did i
realize i control when it eats
when it leaves the house what time it
goes to sleep and pretty much every
aspect of its life
it's very much my pet and in this
episode i realize that the humans are
very much the pets of the machines
so when we see a woman actually try and
have some agency in moving a photo frame
her vacuum bot doesn't like it and
decides to exterminate
so so bad now she has clearly stepped
far too out of line
and thus must be destroyed now the
design of the machine pulls highly from
hal
namely due to the eye in its center this
rogue ai
ended up trying to kill the astronauts
in 2001 a space odyssey
but the similarities to movies about
killer robots don't stop there
there's also a call back to the matrix
when the woman we follow
ducks out of the way in slow motion and
her neighbor arrives with a shotgun to
save her
this is very much in the same vein as
how kyle reese arrived in terminator to
save the day
vacuum bot also scans for its owner with
a blue laser light
which is extremely similar to the
android scene at the start of aliens
now there's some really dark humor in
this including the automated customer
service
constantly trying to lead her down a
path of killing her pet
however she survives the onslaught of
the vacuum bot
and makes it outside unfortunately this
alerts all of the machines in the area
to rise up and pursue them this episode
to me is very much about how the things
you own
end up owning you you may think the
machines that you rely on are
controlled by you but when you rely on
them too much
they end up controlling you the pair are
actually offered the chance to be
whitelisted
at the end of the episode but they say
go to hell showing that they'd perhaps
rather not be subjected to living at the
behest of an automated life anymore and
are now
willing to do things on their own this
is definitely love
death and robots and it's an awesome way
to kickstart the second season
episode two is called ice and it follows
two brothers competing in a deadly race
on a planet far away from earth
they are very much yin and yang and
whereas one has superhuman abilities due
to genetic modifications
one of the brothers sedgwick refuses to
do this the former is the little brother
in this scenario
and his parents very much have him as
the favorite even though serge has
overcome
far more challenges due to his lack of
abilities he's the outsider in this
story
which is very much about conformity
versus individuality
and when he goes to visit the frost
whales we see the character really come
into his own
his brother and his friends are
resistant to the cold or as he's not
and when they're chased by the oceanic
creatures he struggles to keep up
however whereas his friends leave his
brother to die sedg steps in
and saves him this wins him the respect
of his brother
and shows that even though people might
seem different
and less able they often have to work
twice as hard because of this
the group we follow likely only
participate in the race because they
know they can win
whereas for sage it takes true bravery
he also shows far more hot than they do
and overcomes way more challenges in
order to be accepted
it's got a really great message and i
love the art style in this entry too
the blacks and blue mixed together
incredibly well and this duality is of
course seen in the characters themselves
now next up is pop squad and this
follows a cop whose job it is to control
overpopulation by wiping out children in
this world people are given the chance
to live forever
but in doing so they must agree to never
have kids
it's a world overrun by adults and if
people do end up having children
they are quickly exterminated it's one
of the darkest entries in the season
and feels bleak because adults no longer
have a real purpose beyond self-serving
interests whereas people once found
happiness in raising children
and passing on things to the next
generation either through their own kids
or others this world very much feels
like it is stalled
one character named alice says she's
been practicing a singing solo for 20
years
and it shows that humanity hasn't really
moved because any chance at a future or
differing opinions
is quickly wiped out we see that these
so-called illegals are just trying to
live
but the law shows no compassion and
simply views them as something that
takes
rather than gifts thus like pests they
are destroyed
but doing this every day takes a toll on
our protagonist breaks
this neo-noir police drama borrows
heavily from tales of the 1920s
as well as blade runner and of course
its sequel the skyscraper landscapes and
interiors of the police cars
all feel like they're ripped heavily
from it and this episode is
very stylistic now i feel that the
episode metaphorically can be applied to
a number of real world topics
it could very much speak to how
immigrants and refugees are often
demonized by the media and government
so that we don't feel bad in stripping
them of their rights there is a saying
that states no human can be illegal
but this does change things up far
enough away that it could mean something
else
another thought i had whilst watching it
is about how the older generation have
created a world
in which the next one will be subjected
to severe issues caused by global
warming and so on
just in the same way as the characters
in this entry are happy to selfishly
live solely for themselves
it could be viewed as what the elders in
society have done
now before you start yet i know i'm
getting very greta on this
and not to say that i agree or disagree
with either stance
but when you're analyzing things you
often try and guess what the author or
creator is trying to say
of course i'm open to completely
different opinions
so let me know below if you interpreted
this any other way
as i'd love to read your thoughts now
alice jokes about marrying the main
character
and having children with him which makes
him question what he's really living for
he sees the blood on his hands and alice
holds up a toy dinosaur that's
very similar to what one of the murdered
children had briggs joins alisa oriji
treatment
and we see that these people have so
little control over their own lives
that they don't even drive their own
cause they go to investigate a new
parent known as a breeder
who was unable to make his child stop
crying and thus they were found out
however this man would rather die than
live forever without a purpose
and it clearly weighs heavily on breaks
the dinosaur then leads him to a
location
filled with other children's toys these
are now viewed as antiques because of
the lack of kids
and he follows a customer out to her
home where he discovers that she has a
child
he wants to know why people keep having
kids and she states that she's not so in
love with herself that she wants to live
forever
it shows that we must be mindful of what
we're gonna leave behind
and instead of trying to keep things the
same we have to be ready for change
we also have to accept that we aren't
gonna live forever and instead of being
selfish and self-centered
we should think about what we're gonna
leave the world the mother tries to kill
breaks when he drops his god
and though he gets the upper hand he
spares her and the child
showing that he has changed his partner
arrives and
instead he kills her showcasing that he
has broken free of being forced to think
a certain way
he dies defending the child protecting
the future instead of wiping it out
and it's a great way to end one of my
favorite episodes in the run
next we jump to snow in the desert a
bounty hunter centric story
set on a hostile planet with some of the
most realistic looking animated cgi
this side of final fantasy dispersed
within yeah i know i know that's not h12
i've not watched it for years so i don't
know however this hostile desert
environment follows snow
which is a bit of a pun when the planet
is covered inside so i appreciate
that yeah now snow has a big reward in
his head set out by a character called
barris
and after he's challenged and almost
killed he's saved by a mysterious woman
named herald
unfortunately the inhabitants of the
planet attempt to close in on him
and thus he goes to return home now the
story isn't too complicated here and
there's not that much subtext to it
but it does an incredible job of world
building and as i said looks absolutely
gorgeous
we learned that snow is an immortal with
incredible healing abilities
and this is why barris is after him
harold has apparently been sent to take
him in two
but she would rather do the softly
softly catchy monkey approach
his cells hold the key to immortality
but this is of course a power that's
extremely dangerous
if placed into the wrong hands and thus
snow has lived as a recluse
we learn that snow has experienced a lot
of loss because of how long he's lived
and again like the people in the prior
entry he's very much standing still
instead of progressing or changing
his wife ended her own life because she
grew and he didn't
and once more the immortality seems like
somewhat of a curse
the bounty hunters arrive and circle his
home which is where he goes full rampo
on them
and shows how many skills you gain when
you live a long time
the guy would be an even faster youtuber
than me if that's possible which it
isn't
now unfortunately harold is seemingly
murdered in front of him
but it's revealed that she's actually
part cybernetic her body was almost
completely destroyed
and after she kills barris we end with
her kissing snow
saying she's been alone for a long time
too and there are several ways that you
can take the ending
and that either she was working for
earth and wanted to take him back so
that she could use him to regenerate the
missing parts of her body
this could potentially bring her back
however i kind of side with the earth
thing being a lie
i think that she actually wanted to see
if he was truly immortal or not
she has lived a long time because of her
synthetic parts
and has likely found loneliness and
immortality much like how snow had
thus they are now kinded spirits i can
spend an eternity together
now next up is the tall grass which
follows a man from victorian times
who becomes transfixed on ghostly lights
hidden in the shrubbery
i got a lot of vibes of the book in the
tall grass and
during that people became trapped in an
almost infinite corridor of grass
as they were pulled in by malevolent
entities that had the ability to
manipulate time
the people in it were unable to escape
and they became trapped
in their surroundings in the grass the
protagonist lero sees a humanoid
creature moving
and the train he was traveling on starts
to depart without him
as he becomes lost soon he finds himself
facing off against what would happen if
slender man didn't have such a good
tailor
and the character runs for his life
whilst trying to get back to the train
when the creatures pounce he's saved by
the conductor who states that he does
know of the beasts
he very much hints that he thinks there
is another world out there
that sucks lost people into it and
transforms them into the creatures that
we see in this episode
this is allowed to keep occurring
because the tale is so fantastical that
no one would ever believe it
and we end the episode seeing that many
people have been transformed into the
monsters
showing how lucky lara was to escape we
then jump to all through the house
which follows two children on christmas
eve as they tiptoe through the property
to catch a glimpse at center
sounds so heartwarming and a tale that
speaks to the joy and magic of christmas
yay however it's way more sinister than
that
and definitely leaves its presence felt
long after you finish it sorry i
had a fair crap pun in there now what
the pair find is
actually a horrendous and hideous
monster that would make the xenomorph
run to its mummy in this there are
shades of aliens
and pants labyrinth and we discovered
that this is in fact
santa himself the episode is very much
commenting on the commercialization of
holidays i think
and how christmas is very much presented
in a certain way when you're a child
whereas when you're an adult it's an
absolute nightmare
you try getting a turbo man for your
kids now the monster decides if people
are naughty or nice
and when it's this ferocious looking you
can bet that the bad kids
don't have such an easy ride i love this
short and sweet episode as
when i was growing up i always wondered
how it was even possible for santa to
travel around the planet without
being something otherwise also the song
that says he sees you when you're
sleeping
he knows when you're awake which
definitely has a more sinister side to
it
when you really think about it it's a
great little episode and that takes us
to lifehutch
lifehutch involves a pilot played by
michael b jordan
who crash landed on a moon the ship he
lands in looks very similar the one from
beyond the aquila rift
and though much smaller i did appreciate
that there was a little nod to my
favorite episode from last time
the pilot finds a deserted outpost known
as a life hutch
which he should be able to lie low in
however we discover why there's no one
else there
when one of the robots begins to go wild
it's not quite as deadly as the vacuum
bot yeah but the cgi
is absolutely incredible in this to the
point i really struggle to distinguish
whether it was real or not now lace
throughout we see the pilot's mission
and how he came to be and very much got
a lot of allegories of world war
ii stories in which pilots landed behind
enemy lines
they had to be careful in avoiding the
local threats that were there
and it's terrifying watching the machine
stalk the container
destroying anything that moves it's very
much a guard dog on all
fours scanning the area and the episode
feels like it's ripped right out of
black mirror
using his flashlight the pilot is able
to distract the machine
and he destroys it the character sends
out an sos
and fixes his hand so it doesn't look
like mine does
after i write 6 000 words in a day which
most of these scripts tend to be now
thumbs up buttons right there as well by
the way now lastly is the drowned giant
which takes place in jolly old england
after a giants body washes up on a beach
people around it become fascinated over
it the story shows how things that are
regarded as beautiful and wondrous
eventually die and decay now this
episode is clearly playing on wales
washing up on shore
this often happens for a number of
reasons which includes what humanity
does to the ocean
however in real life people don't really
care too much
whereas here they do because the the
giant is human looking
definitely check out see spirits here on
netflix if you haven't and to me this
very much shows how people are in wonder
at it
even though a giant washing up is
something to be worried about
instead of celebrating it shows vast
change in the world that we really
aren't ready for
and yes i'll stop because i'm getting
very very woke either way though
there's no real respect for the corpse
and people climb all over it
his dong's almost as big as mine and we
watch as the body starts to rot over
time
this could hint towards how all things
decay and the scientist that we follow
who studies it
finally decides to step on its body he
becomes very much a representation of
what we all face in death
and whereas we tend to pass away in
privacy the giant is played out on the
beach brawl to see
the scientist slowly begins to see more
and more humanity in its death
and realizes that though we initially
start off as something great
over time we all go the same way the
corpse is cast out to sea
but the remains of the body are
repurposed and placed throughout the
town
and the scientist finds a lot of beauty
and death it shows that after we die
the things that made us are very much
repurposed into the community around us
and it's very much about how we can
still influence things long after we're
gone
though the giant no longer exists the
scientist very much holds a deer
and this final episode speaks to the
nature of life and death
though people pass away we can often
forget their lives
and focus solely on their deaths but we
should remind ourselves of what they
were like in all forms
that's very much what i take from this
episode and it's a somber way to end
this series
now as for the show as a whole i do wish
that we got more of it
the first season was 18 episodes i
believe and this
isn't even half of that however every
episode is enjoyable
i found that there weren't any real duds
in this entry whereas there were several
in the last
it was great getting to watch this and
hopefully with the shorter run time we
see a third season
sooner rather than later anyway that's
our take on every episode of the show
i'd love to hear your thoughts on it and
which one was your favorite
so make sure you comment below and let
me know as a thank you for interacting
with the video you'll be entered into a
prize draw on the 30th of may
in which we're giving away three copies
of the godzilla vs kong collection
all you have to do to be on the chance
of winning is like the video make sure
you subscribe with notifications on and
drop a comment below with your thoughts
on the series
the winners of last month's competition
are on screen right now so if that's you
then message me on twitter heavy
spoilers
if you want something else to watch then
make sure you check out our breakdown of
the final season of castlevania which
will be linked on screen right now
absolutely loved it and there's a ton to
talk about so definitely go check it out
right after this
by the way thank you for sticking
through the video i'll see you next time
take care and enjoy your weekend peace